[Music]
more and more we're seeing machine
learning as a part of everyday things in
your car in your cameras and your
doorbell we wanted to build something to
showcase the technologies and the power
of Android things and so we decided to
build a garden that can kind of react
and interact with the user Android
things is a way to experiment with
machine learning in devices and do it
very rapidly we were brainstorming about
how flowers could become responsive to
people and one of the effects that we
see in the natural world is flowers that
follow the Sun so we had this idea that
the flowers could follow people the
emotion flowers is basically a smart
flower that reacts to a user's facial
expressions that will open when you're
smelling or like when you're winking at
it it'll turn shy and you know close and
turn you know sort of pink so we added a
camera in the head of the flower and it
detected faces and then the algorithm
that did the face detection controlled
the motors in the flower body and slowly
turned it to face people that were
standing there and be a little bit
reactive and responsive we wanted to
just engage people with something that
was aesthetically pleasing beautiful and
so we had a lot of flowers that had
lights leaves built around them these
were active and interactive and people
could stand in front of them so we had
another section where we showed the
Android things processor and the motors
and the cables and the spine and the
vertebrae of this flower and we even let
them control the flower using game
controllers we also use stuff you can
get from the hardware store like copper
piping for the stem and really it's a
matter of like how we put them
together to make it sort of look like
this flower that's not something you'd
see in nature but also convey the idea
that it is a flower there's a spine that
runs up the center of the continuum
robot and we finally found something
called a flex cable that was available
for a weed whacker and we were able to
build the spines which hold the
vertebrae on spines were printed plastic
and then we had to figure out how to
write the software to control this robot
and so we went back to seventh-grade
trigonometry to figure out you know how
much to move the wire caused how much to
move the continuum robot what we wanted
to do was make it super responsive you
go up to the cloud and come back you
have a little bit of a lag and we wanted
our flowers to be organic and natural
and not to show that lag and really the
whole thing is powered by Android things
right and so the idea is you have
sensory inputs in our case it's just the
the camera that senses the scene and
then on device processing so we started
with face recognition software library
that Google has we then we're interested
in how quickly could we recognize faces
in like a video stream on the Raspberry
Pi we detect that there's a face there
and then there's a neuro net that infers
your emotion and so depending on what
the emotion is we changed LED lights or
we move the servo motors to kind of
close and open the petals the platform's
that we have running the hardware that
we have running the Android things
system is quite capable it has a
multi-core processor and it can really
be responsive to changes in a video
stream
anyone who has any inkling to tinker or
to sort of do these DIY hobby type
projects you should just go and give it
a try I think you'll be surprised at
like how quickly you can build sort of
fun wacky interesting guy
and maybe hopefully you'll do something
useful we wanted to showcase both the AI
and these sort of like robotics like
capabilities but the idea is to have
something that's you know approachable
not intimidating but also provide a
delightful experience and so we thought
about trying to sort of scale down the
complexity both physically and also in
the software to to make it into a sort
of a project that we can open-source
there's a hack style page sort of
describe the entire process in very fine
details of how the solder LEDs and
things like that where you can build
your own little flower that sits on your
desk we've kind of carried on sort of
the work a little bit afterward to make
sure that what we've done is available
for the community
[Music]
you